Tom Welling has been kind of quiet in
Hollywood since his gig as Clark Kent of
the CW Smallville ended in 2011 although
he was the original superhero on a
network that since become known for his
comic book shows Welling has yet to
capitalize on the show success to push
into the next stage of his acting career
here's why Hollywood won't cast Tom
Welling anymore super picky Welling
spent a decade on television which can
be very tiring for an actor and it makes
sense that he'd want to take a break
from acting after having to head to the
same set for years as a result Wellings
been very selective in the roles he's
taken since Smallville ended he's only
appeared in three films since the show's
2011 finale the Zac Efron and Billy Bob
Thornton starring mystery drama parkland
the sports drama draft day with Kevin
Costner and the Nicholas Sparks romance
the choice not so super reviews it's not
always the actors fault when the film
doesn't do well but it can definitely
affect their potential for future
success unfortunately none of his post
Smallville films have resonated with
critics or audiences parkland earned a
50% on Rotten Tomatoes in 2013 but even
worse was the fact that it only made 1.4
million at the box office against a 10
million dollar budget a year later draft
day did slightly better earning a 60% on
Rotten Tomatoes and bringing in a box
office hollow 29.5 million against a
budget of 25 million the choice from
2016 performed the worst of all three
with critics earning only a 12 percent
on Rotten Tomatoes it wasn't a total
box-office failure though grossing just
over 23 million worldwide against in
approximately 10 million dollar budget
of course none of the three films were
impressive enough to prove Wehling star
power outside a small film which could
make Studios nervous to cast him in
big-budget films inexperienced Welling
was new to Hollywood when he booked a
six episode arc on the judging a me
which led to a starring role in
Smallville his lack of experience was
pretty obvious in some of the earlier
episodes
cutman what's wrong
Clyde man was wrong
and a subsequent 10-year stint on the
show also meant that Clark Kent became
Wellings most immediately identifiable
role making it even harder for him to
break out into other parts later locked
in the involved visual effects that
Smallville demanded meant that Welling
was on set more than most other actors
would have to be giving him less time to
pursue other projects the roles he did
appear in include the ill-received
horror film the fog with Maggie Grace
and selma Blair and most notably the
role of Charlie Baker in the Cheaper by
the Dozen series in the end Welling
wasn't called upon to carry a lot of
dramatic weight many of those roles
making Smallville the most impressive
line on his resume behind the scenes the
former Clark Kent launched Tom Welling
productions towards the end of
Smallville's run with a goal of spending
more time behind the camera Welling who
began executive producing during the
later episodes of Smallville served as
an executive producer on the CW's
cheerleader drama d Hellcats in 2011
Welling also directed a few episodes of
Smallville over the years and told the
LA Times after the show ended that
directing was a new ambition it's
possible that his acting career lost
some momentum because he's focused on
pursuing other opportunities behind the
camera failure to launch
when Welling decided that he was finally
ready to return to acting and television
in 2015 his pilot project from Tom
Welling Productions and executive
produced by the actor ended up not
working out section 13 was set to follow
Welling as a CIA black ops officer who
becomes a private contractor in a covert
organization devoted to carrying out the
most difficult and dangerous high-stakes
assignments however the season was
crowded for CBS that year and the pilot
was not ordered to series how he can
turn his career around Welling is
clearly a talented actor as he
demonstrated during his 10 years as a
lead on Smallville but maybe instead of
trying to shed his superhero past he
should lean in after all it worked for
one former Kryptonian Brendan Ralph
after his one-and-done lead role in
Superman Returns in 2006 Ralph had
trouble finding his footing then he was
cast as super scientist Ray Palmer
better known as the atom in the CW slate
of comic book shows
now he's got a recurring role on legends
of tomorrow with more super themed shows
and movies being announced all the time
there's no reason why Welling couldn't
follow suit and show off his action and
comedy chops that kind of role can help
him lose his Clark Kent image while
still keeping the heart and charm that
attracted audiences in the first place
it probably won't happen faster than a
speeding bullet but we hope to see
Welling regularly on screen again soon
thanks for watching click on the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to